of residents who feel like they aren't
being heard are there any plans to do
like a town hall or something like that
where you can address them directly and
the residents can can voice their
concerns to you
I met with families
and that's who the focus is on but
there's more than just the family's
impact right fully aware and we're in
front of you every day
ma'am are we talking to some businesses
and residents in the area who are
concerned about other buildings in the
area are you aware of other buildings in
the area with structural problems and
are you going to send teams in now to
take another look at those so I've said
before we're constantly looking at that
yes we're looking at every cycle of
one more two more and then we're done
you get well you get one a person
[Music]
spots at least one in particular there
was a lot of barking kind of you guys
touch on that I mean have there been any
hits on either remains or uh
on the Disco
um
yeah the the the dogs have been on site
and they have worked they provide an
alert to the handlers and then the
handlers decipher what that alert means
through their training in nxt's
they've had alerts um that have
given the Handler's information to
ascertain what that is canines are
fantastic
they do wonderful things for us canines
like everybody can be oversaturated at
times and so it's really hard to
decipher after because they get stressed
too just like we do I mean a lot of us
probably have pets and so we can
we can understand when animals are
stressed and so as the dogs give alerts
the handlers then decipher those alerts
best decided upon the environmental
conditions that they're working in
is there any kind of a timeline of when
there might be inspectors sent or or
folks that are living or if business is
in this other building timeline of
inspection not a timeline today but we
are constantly like this whole tragedy
we're constantly evaluating where when
and what do we send and how we do that
okay last one is it anything been
recovered as far as human remains before
anybody found
we can't disclose that yet
um could this happen last one would you
have
we launched it Sunday
thank you for your time
now begin there will be no more
scheduled if there's some significant
update that we need to provide either it
will be provided in writing or we will
call you but there is no scheduled
update here
until Monday
yeah No 2 p.m today the next
Monday Monday at 10
um and if something happens that we need
to get there's something significant we
will get in touch with you thank you
because